[Música]
aquí comienza el debate de France 24 Mi
nombre es Ángela Gómez nuestro tema es
el Día Mundial contra el cáncer de mama
una de cada 12 mujeres lo sufrirán a lo
largo de su vida con más de dos coma dos
millones de casos en el mundo Según uno
de los datos recamados en el año 2020
por la Organización Mundial de la Salud
además es el cáncer más común para
conversar sobre este tema hemos invitado
a gracia de Michelle doctora en historia
contemporánea Y actualmente hace su
segundo doctorado en historia en la
universidad de Génova en Italia además
es una mujer que vive con cáncer de mama
también nos acompaña David Puerto
quienes coordinadora de salud pública
del Instituto Nacional es de cánceres de
Colombia ambas un agradecimiento
especial y a nuestros televidentes les
recuerdo que también son parte del
debate dejen sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
estamos en Twitter Facebook e Instagram
no se encuentran como arroba el debate
f24 y @ 24 la etiqueta es numeral el
debate f24 y no olviden que todos son
los contenidos de nuestro programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast Spotify
deezer y también en TuneIn
para comenzar veamos un ejemplo en
Brasil desde cada año se detectan cerca
de 66.000 casos nuevos de cáncer de mama
estudios científicos se revelan que el
30% de ellos podrían ser controlados
gracias a una detección precoz sin
embargo la pandemia del coronavirus
ralentizó la realización de mamografías
y de otras pruebas diagnósticas en este
octubre Rosa reconocemos a Beto un
tatuador de Río de Janeiro que usa su
Don artístico para reconstruir de forma
gratuita los pezones de las mujeres que
pasaron por una mastectomía y por una
posterior reconstrucción mamaria
en abril de 2020 el mundo de Karla se
vino abajo en plena pandemia descubrió
durante un examen de rutina que tenía un
cáncer maligno en el pezón
el diagnóstico fue complicado porque
porque me pidió en un momento de
sufrimiento
un mes Antes había perdido a mi madre
los médicos se retiraron la areola de su
seno además Karla Tuvo que pasar por un
ciclo de quimioterapia
al final esta mujer consiguió vencer la
enfermedad a sus 41 años solo desea
volver a la normalidad
me siento un poco yo me siento un poco
mutilada no tengo mucho valor de mirarme
en el espejo porque sé que está faltando
una parte de mí mismo
Hoy es el día en que Carla va a
recuperar su autoestima gracias al
trabajo solidario de un tatuador
hace 11 años Beto realiza tatuajes
gratuitos a mujeres que perdieron sus
mamás
ya te hicieron un injerto alguna vez
Beto examina los pechos de Carla para
poder copiar exactamente su pezón
es un procedimiento rápido pero muy
preciso en poco más de media hora Beto
tatúa la areola completa el resultado es
espectacular
[Música]
yo no veía Carla veía otra persona Ahora
estoy viendo a la Carla de verdad
decenas de mujeres han vuelto a sonreír
gracias a la generosidad de este
profesional que no cobra por este
servicio
otros tatuadores en el mundo podrían ver
eso sensibilizarse y ayudar otros
tatuadores podrían unirse a hacer la
misma cosa porque no cuesta nada es un
trabajo de 40 minutos que va a dar
felicidad a una mujer por el resto de su
vida
Beto sigue cuidando de esas mujeres
incluso después del tatuaje alguna como
Marcia vuelve a por otro un lazo rosa
que identifica a las pacientes
oncológicas
vamos a empezar por la importancia de la
detección temprana que es cuando la
enfermedad todavía se encuentra
localizada y para ello pregunto Cuáles
son las recomendaciones primero quisiera
comenzar con gracia de Michelle
Hola Sí bueno
yo no está en la posición de las
comandar nada porque soy una
historiadora y una activista
seguramente
la decisión precoz es importante pero
también lo que cuenta mucho en la
sobrevivencia
es la biología del tumor digamos que los
los cánceres de mama se pueden
distinguir en más o menos tres tipos
un primer tipo es un cáncer que
es invasivo Es decir que se puede
difundir a otros a otras partes del
cuerpo pero se
encuentra Cuando Aún está localizado en
el pecho o en los ganglios
Y responde a las terapias disponibles
actualmente
hay otro tipo de cáncer de mama que no
pone en peligro la vida de la persona de
la mujer que lo parece y pero al mismo
tiempo
hoy en día
basándonos en los conocimientos que son
un limitados que tenemos
lo tratamos y a veces las pacientes se
ponen enfermas después por culpa de los
tratamientos y hay un tercer tipo de
cáncer de mama que
desafortunadamente es muy agresivo no
responde a los tratamientos disponibles
actualmente y la paciente se muera y de
hecho se muere y por ejemplo
hoy en día en la mayoría de los países
de Europa occidental y Estados Unidos un
30% de las en un 30% de los casos
de cáncer de mama son fatales para para
las mujeres
viene y te vi su recomendación desde su
lugar de trabajo y desde su rol de
combate contra el cáncer de mama
bueno Muchas gracias definitivamente la
detección temprana de este cáncer es
fundamental para mejorar la sobre vida
de las pacientes y reducir la mortalidad
es necesario que acudamos a las pruebas
de tamización que la mamografía en este
caso es la prueba indicada en nuestro
país en Colombia está recomendada a
partir de los 50 años hasta los 69 años
cada dos años y las mujeres a partir de
los 40 años deben acudir a un examen
clínico de la mamá en médico por el
médico general Pues que tiene un
entrenamiento específico para este
examen clínico se realiza anualmente y
adicionalmente concientizar a las
mujeres frente al autoexamen como una
medida de conocimiento de amor propio
para aprender a conocer nuestras mamás e
identificar signos o síntomas de una
manera temprana bueno sin embargo débil
sobre todo en América Latina son muchos
los casos de mujeres menores de 40 años
que están presentando cáncer mama esa es
una Se podría decir que una pandemia que
está sucediendo en esta parte del
continente si uno lo contrasta por
ejemplo con países como Estados Unidos O
como Canadá que otros exámenes O medidas
preventivas se pueden tomar para
determinar si hay riesgo de padecer la
enfermedad Ya no de si está presente en
nuestro cuerpo sino si podríamos por
ejemplo por un factor hereditario llegar
a tener cáncer de mama
Bueno de hecho nuestro país el 67% de
las mujeres en Colombia son
diagnosticadas sobre los 50 años hay que
diferenciar muy bien la tamización de la
detección temprana las mujeres no
importa la edad que tengan signos o
síntomas deben acudir de inmediato a los
servicios de salud para brindarles todas
las pruebas diagnósticas necesarias esta
detección temprana es independiente de
la edad la tamización es cuando no hay
signos y no hay síntomas y buscamos
identificar la enfermedad en etapas muy
tempranas ahora bien
población que tiene riesgo aumentado
Como por ejemplo las mujeres con
mutaciones familiares con riesgos
genéticos hereditarios que tienen
también unas medidas muy especiales y
requieren iniciar la tamización en
edades muy tempranas pero esta población
en riesgo es La minoría la mayoría de
las mujeres con cáncer de mama no tenían
signos
o síntomas
identificables de una manera pronta y no
tenían un factor hereditario es decir
nosotros nos debemos enfocar en la
población general en la población
promedio lo que tú dices es muy cierto
hay mujeres menores de 50 años mujeres
jóvenes que presentan esta enfermedad
por lo tanto es necesario hacer el
autoexamen cada mes para conocer
nuestras mamás consultar de inmediato
ante cualquier cambio y desde los 40
hacer el examen clínico de la mama
anualmente pero sin importar la edad hay
que acudir de inmediato a los servicios
de salud lo lo que pasa es que la
mamografía como prueba de tamización
antes de los 50 años presenta algún
riesgo de tener falsos positivos falsos
negativos y reduce la sensibilidad y la
especificidad porque en mujeres jóvenes
las mamás son muy densas entonces puede
ocasionar errores en la lectura por eso
se recomienda nuestro país desde los 50
pero esto no quiere decir que las
mujeres en cualquier edad con signos o
síntomas puedan acudir de inmediato al
servicio de salud es una alerta y este
mes Rosa y la fecha de conmemoración de
cáncer de mama Nos invita a esta
concientización a todas las mujeres sin
importar la edad y también a los hombres
no
Gracias leyendo un poco acerca de su
historia y de lo que usted ha compartido
en internet usted ha dicho que uno de
sus grandes cuestionamientos cuando
descubrió la enfermedad es que el cáncer
no puede aparecer porque sí y que muchas
veces no hay explicación para las
mujeres que lo padecen qué respuestas ha
encontrado a lo largo de Pues de estos
años en los que se ha dedicado a crear
su blog a hacer activismo y pues a
encontrar redes de apoyo en otras
mujeres
sí es una pregunta que me dice desde el
principio y de hecho me quedé bastante
sorprendida porque fue la primera
pregunta que hice a la doctora que me
comunico a mi diagnóstico y y me
contestó que es imposible saberlo pero
al mismo tiempo me dijo que estaba
segura que me iba a curar y yo soy una
historiadora Entonces mi trabajo es
establecer
conexiones de causa y efectos entre los
fenómenos entonces me parecía bastante
raro que después de tantos años de
investigación de tanto dinero que se ha
recaudado también con
a través de
fechas como como esta a través de la
sorosa aún no se sabe prácticamente nada
de las causas del cáncer de mama sobre
todo en las mujeres jóvenes Y sin
ninguna factor de riesgo y sin ninguna
mutación genética hereditaria como yo
y al mismo tiempo me parecía muy raro
que
a pesar desde esta falta de conocimiento
sobre las causas
esa doctora y todo los otros doctores
los otros médicos de los otros
profesionales de la salud con que ha
hablado siempre me han dicho que estaban
seguros que me iba que iba a sobrevivir
que me iba a curar
y
sigo sigo preguntándomelo Y pregunta
haciendo esta pregunta pero el problema
es que las causas no no se conocen hay
seguramente más exposición a
interferentes
endocrinos en mi caso por ejemplo y
también factores y andrógenos por
ejemplo en mi caso
cuando mi madre estaba embarazada
le dieron una como tenía más de 35 años
le dieron mucha progesterona y ahora
están saliendo estudios que
muestran como la exposición a una forma
particular de progesterona sintética
durante la vista en útero pueden
hacen subir el riesgo de desarrollar
cáncer y también cáncer de mama
entonces
lo que hizo a través de mi experiencia
es que se seguramente entre las mujeres
hay
esta necesidad de
saber el más sobre las causas del cáncer
de forma que se pueda prevenir el cáncer
verdaderamente O sea no Simplemente
detectarlo de forma precoz cuando ya
está ahí
si no
evitar la exposición en voluntaria a
factores que aumentan nuestro riesgo de
desarrollar la enfermedad bueno Y si
hablamos un poco de esos factores porque
uno de los datos que me llamaban la
atención al leer sobre este tema es que
por ejemplo las mujeres que lactan a sus
bebés durante varios meses podrían
disminuir ese riesgo de cáncer de mama
por el contrario como usted lo
mencionaba una mujer que decide ser
madre después de los 35 años podría
estar aumentando su riesgo de padecer
este cáncer lo mismo una mujer que por
alguna razón decide o no puede lactar a
su bebé es decir hay varios factores de
riesgo pero hay algunos que están
demasiado abiertos Entonces por ejemplo
el consumo de alcohol podría aumentar el
riesgo de cáncer de mama pero Qué es un
alto consumo de alcohol en Qué
cantidades para qué mujeres Qué grupos
poblacionales
claro Sí sí es absolutamente así de
hecho Estos factores de riesgo conocidos
no no aparecen en el más o menos ese 70%
de los casos de alumnos en Europa
occidental y en Estados Unidos entonces
la pregunta va sobre la las preguntas
sobre las causas están siempre ahí
o sea si es en el 70% de los casos
no no hay este factores de riesgos
supuestamente conocidos Cuál es la causa
del cáncer de mama en los años 90s
había un movimiento de base entre las
mujeres estadounidenses
que
pidieron al Gobierno Federal más
investigación precisamente sobre las
causas de la enfermedad
y creo que aún están esperando que se
investigue más al respecto porque sea se
hizo más investigación sobre los
tratamientos de algunas formas de cáncer
de mama porque decir cáncer de mama es
como no decir nada porque hay de
muchísimos tipos y distinto uno dentro
de otro uno desde otro
y
por algunos sí
se han hemos avanzado en términos de
tratamientos
pero en términos de conocimientos sobre
las causas absolutamente no
quisiera preguntarle ahora usted porque
también es importante tener en cuenta lo
dijimos hoy en nuestro canal y en las
últimas jornadas que se prevé Un aumento
de los diagnósticos de los casos que
podrían llegar hasta el 40% más para el
año 2040 porque este aumento de los
diagnósticos como interviene la ciencia
en este caso
bueno el número
de mamá tiende el incremento también
relacionado con el envejecimiento
poblacional cada vez la población se
hace mayor y aumenta también los
diagnósticos del cáncer adicionalmente
cada vez se diagnostican mejor los casos
antiguamente no eran tan buenos el
proceso de diagnóstico de cáncer en las
poblaciones Y eso hace que además del
envejecimiento estemos detectando cada
vez mejor el cáncer antes las mujeres
muchas veces morían sin saber que había
muerto de Cáncer y sobre todo en zonas
dispersas son las Rurales en zonas donde
no había servicios de salud pues
cercanos adicionalmente la
industrialización ha hecho que aumenten
algunos factores de riesgo como la
obesidad el sedentarismo consumo de
alcohol consumo de tabaco el consumo de
alimentos Ultra procesados todas estas
acciones de la modernidad han hecho que
también se incremente el riesgo de este
tipo de Cáncer y vaya en aumento
cómo se explican las disparidades entre
por ejemplo una mujer estadounidense y
una latinoamericana ambas diagnosticadas
con cáncer de seno y le pongo Este
ejemplo porque fallecen más mujeres en
América Latina por padecer cáncer de
seno que mujeres en Estados Unidos y
claro esta premisa de que aumenta la
tecnología y aumenta la capacidad para
diagnosticar el cáncer pues es correcta
pero también hay otro lado y es el lado
de la discriminación de la desigualdad
de las mujeres que no tienen la
posibilidad para hacerse estos exámenes
y para tener una atención integral
cuando llega el momento
sí Bueno de hecho se diagnostican mucho
más cáncer en países desarrollados la
incidencia la tasas de incidencias son
mayor pero la mortalidad sí es mayor en
países como los nuestros países en vías
de desarrollo en América Latina y esto
se debe también a los servicios de salud
en países desarrollados tenemos
programas mucho más organizados tenemos
un mayor acceso a los servicios de salud
y es muy definitivo el rápido o el
pronto acceso al diagnóstico y al
tratamiento en países de América Latina
como en nuestro se presentan barreras
acceso a los servicios de salud no todas
las mujeres objeto de los programas de
tamización reciben su mamografía en
Colombia aproximadamente el 75% de las
mujeres tiene su mamografía de
tamización en la edad de objeto Pero
esto no sucede en todas las ciudades hay
zonas remotas en donde hay dificultades
de acceso a los servicios de salud y las
no reciben sus mamografías y
adicionalmente hablaba de estas barreras
para que puedan tener
diagnósticos más oportunos que puedan
tener un pronto inicio del tratamiento
es Espera que nuestro país en menos de
un mes las mujeres ya tengan su su
tratamiento Pero eso no sucede siempre
tenemos una oportunidad o días de espera
para esto de moradas y lo que usted
hablaba la inequidades se presentan
También en estos países no todas las
mujeres tienen acceso a servicios
universales de salud no todas las
mujeres tienen acceso a servicios de
calidad un factor determinante también
es el control de calidad
muchas veces los equipos no tienen estos
controles de calidad necesarios para
evitar falsos positivos falsos negativos
o evitar problemas con la radiación
entre otros aspectos determinantes de la
calidad Entonces es el problema de la
detección temprana es grande cobija la
calidad
tengas eso cobija también tener
oportunidad de calidad en los
diagnósticos Entonces es un problema que
nos involucra a todos y les guste dice
es muy cierto hay aún muchas iniquidades
y discriminación para muchas mujeres en
América Latina viene la siguiente
pregunta va para las dos y quisiera
comenzar con gracia se cumplen este año
30 años desde la creación de la campaña
llamada lazo rosa o conocida como el
lazo rosa que fue creada en Estados
Unidos por la empresaria Evelyn los Def
de estilodea y que creó esta fundación
de investigaciones del cáncer de seno Y
a esta fundación si viene le debemos
avances para para conocer sobre el
cáncer de mama y sobre todo cómo
mantenernos con vida si es que llega el
momento de sufrir la enfermedad Pues
también el lazo rosa se ha asociado con
una muy amplia campaña de publicidad que
No necesariamente aporta a las víctimas
sino que más bien las invisibiliza En
ese sentido Usted qué opina gracia nos
representa o representa
Bueno antes de contestar a la pregunta
quería Añadir una pequeña cosa porque
hay una pequeña historia detrás de la
historia de las rosas de
el primer lazo por el cáncer de mama no
era rosa si no era más color melocotón
color salmón y lo había
los hacía esos pequeños lazos una mujer
que vivía en California y se llamaba
Charlotte Halley
pertenecía a este movimiento que había
en Estados Unidos al principio de los
90s que
pedían el Gobierno Federal de hacer más
investigación sobre las causas del
cáncer de mama y esta mujer había tenido
muchas familiares que habían muerto por
cáncer de mama Y entonces se había
movilizado se había unido al movimiento
había empezado se había inspirado
por el por el sida y había empezado a
hacer estos pequeños lazos en su casa y
los pegaba después a una postal donde
estaba Donde había escrito de pedir más
dinero por la investigación sobre las
causas del cáncer de mama al gobierno y
iba en los supermercados distribuyendo
estas estas postales con los lacitos
color color melocotón y también escribía
periodistas y una periodista publicó su
historia y Evelyn y
Alexandra Penny quien Aquellos tiempos
será la directora de un periódico
estadounidense que se llamaba self
[Música]
estaban buscando un símbolo para
su campaña que iban a hacer ya habían
hecho el año como el año antes en 1991
sobre el cáncer de mama e iban a repetir
en 1992 y preguntaron a esta mujer si
querían si quería darle a ellas su lazo
Charlotte Cali contestó que no que era
un lazo demasiado comercial que es
simplemente ellas querían vender sus
productos los cosméticos de este luder y
le dijo que no Entonces
la Evelyn luder preguntó a sus a sus
abogados lo que podía hacer y le
aconsejaron de cambiar el color y el
color que le fue elegido fue Rosa que es
un color muy que tranquiliza mucho y que
pero está asociado con una enfermedad
Como el cáncer de mama que no tiene nada
de tranquilizante para las mujeres
porque es una enfermedad que pone
que hace mucho miedo
evidentemente
y con el tiempo sea también
comercializado mucho entonces hoy en día
simplemente se pone un las rosas sobre
un producto simplemente para aumentar
las
para hacer más propósitos sobre las
venidas de las ventas del producto y es
por eso que
bastante mujeres con cáncer de mama en
los primeros tres estadio de la
enfermedad Ya no se reconocen en él Y
todavía más las mujeres que parecen
cáncer de mama metastásico porque
claramente es la el cuarto estadio el
estadio final de la enfermedad lo que no
es rosa para nada que no ayuda no ayuda
a vender productos Y entonces está
totalmente invisibilizado
de mis opiniones
Bueno yo Considero que el lazo rosa ha
permitido a nivel internacional que
personas empresas organizaciones se unan
a crear conciencia en la lucha contra
esta enfermedad y esto ha hecho que cada
vez más empresas se sumen a esta
iniciativa y que cada vez el
conocimiento llegue a las mujeres de
diferentes regiones sin embargo lo que
yo he visto es que se le ha cargado
Mucho peso a las mujeres frente a que se
hagan el autoexamen entonces hemos visto
en algunas poblaciones que se genera
antes miedo que si no si no se hace el
otro examen entonces va a tener un
diagnóstico Y si tienen diagnóstico se
le genera la culpa del porque no se hizo
el autoexable y lo que hemos tratado
nosotros desde el Instituto Nacional de
cancerología es que no Únicamente se le
carga este peso a las mujeres
diagnosticadas en que no se hicieron un
adecuado tu examen sino que
definitivamente esto es un conjunto de
acciones que contribuyen a la detección
temprana y es favorecer muchísimo más e
involucrar a las mujeres sobrevivientes
de cáncer es decir cada vez involucrar
las acciones de conciencia también hasta
sobrevivientes que tienen mucho por dar
y mucho por educar a otra mujeres
Entonces creo que aún nos falta mucho
más para hacer que este lazo represente
a las mujeres sobrevivientes y Tenemos
también que mejorar un poco el
simbolismo frente a este miedo que se le
puede generar a las mujeres relación al
autoexamen pero sí ha permitido generar
conciencia en las poblaciones recaudar
fondos para investigaciones y ha
permitido Pues que cada vez más personas
hablen de esta enfermedad Bueno pero lo
que sí podemos decir es que el lazo
evidentemente si ha causado un efecto de
romanticismo alrededor de la enfermedad
que por ejemplo cuando vemos las
publicidades al respecto se asocian
mucho con la ternura con la suavidad
pero pues hay muchas realidades más allá
de eso que nos describía hace un momento
gracias entonces les pido que hablemos
por un momento de ello Hablemos del
dolor físico del dolor de huesos en las
lesiones en la piel la pérdida de
cabello eventualmente la pérdida de una
parte tan importante de nuestro cuerpo
porque la enfermedad es a veces es tan
normalizada que se nos olvida lo que
realmente es ser una persona que padece
uno de los cánceres más comunes en el
mundo Gracias a comienzo con usted
y así es Es como dices tú o sea
normalizado completamente la enfermedad
o sea es normal que una mujer a una
cierta edad tenga un cáncer de mama y
no es normal para nada
y no es normal tener que
tener que pasar por una mastectomía por
una quimioterapia
por por ejemplo como
pasa en el caso de la forma más común de
cáncer de mama por un tratamiento
endocrino que ahora
se suministra durante 10 años
y tiene muchos efectos secundarios por
ejemplo uno de los medicamentos que más
se utiliza en el mundo
y que se llama tamoxifeno
tiene como efectos secundario Un aumento
significativo del riesgo de desarrollar
un cáncer de útero
y claro después de haber tenido ya un
cáncer de mama
tener que tomar todos los días un
medicamento que aumenta el riesgo de
desarrollar otro cáncer es muy duro
también desde un punto de vista
psicológico
la
prácticamente casi todas las mujeres con
que he hablado me han dicho y son muchas
me han dicho que la vida no vuelve como
como antes en el sentido que sigue con
el miedo que se pueda obtener una
recaída
y No es simplemente miedo sino que si el
cáncer de mama puede puede volver
también después de 20 años por ejemplo
como pasó muy recientemente en el caso
de la actriz Olivia Newton
Y entonces se sigue viviendo en el miedo
del cáncer de mama de otras enfermedades
que se pueden desarrollar por como
efectos secundarios de los medicamentos
por el cáncer de mama
y es una
es algo que sí que
por encima tenemos siempre
las mujeres que
tienen la enfermedad
como casi como tienen que
siempre seguir sonriendo y ser
optimistas y ser positivas y contar el
como el cuento de hadas de la enfermedad
que nos ha cambiado la vida y nos ha
mejorado No creo que es así
Y usted como coordinadora de salud
pública como una persona que conoce el
tema desde el interior y que lo ha
vivido con las pacientes cuéntenos por
favor ya vamos cerrando las
implicaciones de vivir la enfermedad
cuando entendemos que la mayoría de
víctimas la gran mayoría de víctimas son
mujeres y que detrás de una mujer vienen
los hijos vienen los padres vienen todas
las redes comunitarias que son parte de
la red de Cuidado de las mujeres es
decir la gravedad que es el hecho de que
una mujer que está encargada de las
tareas de Cuidado pierda su salud
Sí de hecho como lo decían ustedes Esta
no es una patología para romantizar
porque matan cada año en nuestro país
mueren más de tres mil mujeres por esta
enfermedad y es una enfermedad que no le
afecta sobre la paciente tenía los
servicios de salud como usted lo decía
es una enfermedad que afecta a todo el
núcleo familiar es una mujer que debe
dejar de producir dejar de trabajar
requiere unos cuidados especiales está
su familia y adicionalmente cambios
físicos importantes es una enfermedad
para varios años que requiere un
tratamiento
farmacológico bastante largo en donde
durante el tratamiento se tienen Si se
quiere decir así pérdidas importantes en
la autoestima por pérdida del cabello
puede ser por una mastectomía por
dolores físicos importantes Entonces
esto es una enfermedad que involucra la
autoestima de la mujer su calidad de
vida su economía su vida social y su
vida familiar en ese sentido si
necesitamos muchísima red de apoyo y
trabajo con los cuidadores porque no es
fácil enfrentarse a esta enfermedad que
es de la familia requerimos apoyo para
la familia apoyo para la paciente y todo
un proceso de apoyo y de tejido social
en donde necesitamos ser más compasivos
con nuestras pacientes en donde
necesitamos generar mayor apoyo del
estado de la sociedad y poderle dar a
estas mujeres un soporte para que puedan
superar la enfermedad Claro que sí que
después puede ser unas mujeres que
puedes demostradas como fuertes
resilientes sobrevivientes pero mientras
se da la enfermedad necesitan muchísimo
apoyo muchísimos cuidados y todo un
soporte que necesitamos mejorar porque
las estamos dejando un poco solas no es
solamente el medicamento ni el servicio
de salud hay un trasfondo importante
económico
Hermosillo bueno muchas cosas en las que
debemos apoyar a las mujeres por lo
menos en el instituto tenemos talleres
con organizaciones de la sociedad civil
en donde se les enseñan a hacer muchas
actividades por ejemplo actividades de
cómo lucir el cabello o pelucas de hacer
pañoletas de otras cosas
solamente dos minutos de programa le
quiero pedir muy rápidamente su
conclusión pero me parece muy importante
todo lo que menciona y aquí yo quisiera
cerrar este programa hablando de que nos
convertimos todos en una red de Cuidado
tanto si la persona es una paciente con
cáncer de mama como si es una persona
que tiene alguien que quiere que padece
la enfermedad o siendo una mujer Pues
tiene usted O tengo yo la posibilidad de
sufrir la enfermedad Así que para el
cierre les quisiera pedir a las dos muy
rápidamente la conclusión de la
importancia de tener redes de apoyo
listo Bueno mi conclusión es que esta es
una enfermedad que nos involucra a todos
y en ese sentido debemos convertirnos en
apoyo si somos pacientes dejarnos ayudar
y vivir el proceso y si somos cuidadores
capacitarnos entrenarnos y entre todos
poderle brindar a nuestras mujeres con
cáncer una tranquilidad de que va a
estar bien vamos a salir adelante y cada
vez Vamos a luchar porque se detecte más
tempranamente la enfermedad bien Y
gracias
Sí seguramente es importante la barra de
apoyo y no solo desde un punto de vista
físico sino también desde un punto de
vista político a mí me salvó
literalmente de la vida y el alma una
sensación estadounidense que se llama
Andrés Cancer action y que trabaja
Porque baje la incidencia del cáncer de
mama y se haga más prevención primaria o
sea se vaya más de las mamografías y de
Rosa Pues gracias a las dos por
compartirnos sus historias su
experiencia valiosísima y sobre todo
todo lo que todavía nos falta por
entender sobre este tema Eso es todo por
hoy En nombre del equipo Les agradecemos
su sintonía la producción de este
programa estuvo a cargo de Laura garzón
y la producción de invitados a cargo de
Tania Herrera y Samuel Salgado gracias a
ustedes nos vemos próximamente
[Música]